yeah welcome to this video yeah this
looks different I know and this is
because this is played on yet another
platform this is
chess24.com
um yeah that's a new server but it's not
really about the server that this is
about I'm playing against a very strong
grandm here German champion of 2010
Nicholas henbit he challenged me to um
um to a dual commentary game so we are
ready to
um yeah plays two Blitz games um four
plus two time control and um he will do
commentary on his channel and I'll of
course do it on mine okay I need to
think about this this is the the Evans
Gambit and yeah note that I'm a huge
Underdog here in terms of uh um in terms
of rating simply because I never play
here on the server I'm just totally new
I played one or two games and Blitz and
you start with 18800 yeah D6 here is a
very um yeah very simple solution to the
Evans Gambit that um is not really yeah
meant to be uh especially brilliant for
black but it's meant to um yeah get um a
decent playable game without any um any
huge trouble um B5 and queen C7 I think
is what I should do um can he sacrifice
I don't think
so not really Queen has to retreat and
then I go Queen
C7 Queen C7 and probably Bishop F4 can
be answered with Bishop D6 so he has to
retreat yeah I have returned the pawn
trying to get a solid position there are
more critical tries against the Evans
but um yeah I had no time to prepare for
this match I knew he placed the scam but
he won a very um well-known game against
grandmas Yan Gustafson in the German
championships a while back when um he
totally busted Gus's um Gus's
preparation um yeah Knight F6 to allow
E5 not sure that I want
that but yeah but otherwise I don't see
how I develop my my pieces E5 Knight D5
at least gives my knight a good Square
on D5 slightly behind on the clock and
um not exactly on on my home turf need
to um sort of adjust to the board and
stuff but it's looking okay right I
think it's uh something that um is easy
on the
eyes or is it easy on the eye this one
of those expressions where you only have
a one one way to to say it um yeah
should I try that I'd like to simplify
matters
maybe if I if he goes Bishop H4 I think
Knight H5 is a is a welcome trade for
me possibly I can go to F4 or at least
if he takes Queen takes my queen has a
good spot on E7 Knight F4 is quite a
quite a useful move in any case it looks
a bit strange to have both Knights on
the edge of the board but at the moment
I don't really see a a problem with
it my development is pretty okay the
only real argument against black setup
is that um well besides the knights that
um I have somewhat
offside um I have I have a pawn um a
pawn Less in the
center um okay so how do I play that now
Bishop E6 and I have two Bishops yeah
which is
nice I wonder he probably will go Knight
to D4 and maybe I should put put this on
the long diagonal then Rook E8 control
E5 just um trying
to claim that I'm I'm okay with my
Bishops anyway he can maybe play A4 but
I have B4 so it's nothing that I'm
terribly afraid
of yeah this um Bishop E7 I think is uh
and and returning the porn is a decent
recipe against the Evans it's a sort of
a low maintenance
approach um yeah what am I doing now it
uh it's not that this threatens very
much but like B4 maybe I can I would
like to play C5 so maybe I should
prepare that if he goes A4 I think
B4 could be
good my development I would like to get
my Rooks connected this is really a
deficit in my or drawback of my position
oh this is an aggressive move a really
aggressive
move yeah C5 looks like looks like the
way to go kicking the
Knight F4 is aggressive but it also
comes with some uh some weaknesses um
connected to it if I go B4 he will
probably take it yeah or will play E5
maybe just E5 yeah that's that's
possible I wonder if I should just put
the bishop
on maybe maybe it's maybe this bishop E7
to C5 trying to go on the dark
squares not very much afraid of a king
side attack maybe maybe this is is uh
this is wrong I tend to be too
optimistic against the Texs
but we'll see what
happens it's got Knight E4 yeah Knight
E4 is a
move
huh ah very tough very tough but at
least I'm head on the clock what I
really need to get used to is the the
relatively small clock on the right hand
side I wasn't really paying any
attention to that
uh I mean I couldn't even tell you what
what clock time we had um if I take it
now and Knight C6 is this an idea come
on let's try
to ah he has got D5 okay so I should
probably start with this first D5 Knight
before Queen E4 was a problem
but okay Rook d8 yeah this D4 Pawn is is
not especially
strong if he takes it Queen takes Knight
F3 Knight C6 should be okay but there
might be some sort of I mean white white
definitely will get an attack here he
will definitely get some sort of
attack Knight F3 Knight C6 Queen E4 yeah
not good or let's
say less Le less good than it first
seems to
be this F5 F6 business uh still can be
very tricky so if I
go he wants to put it on D6
yeah uh not easy I can take it and then
Knight KN then the Knight over to B7
would be
nice I me
just put it here I could have taken them
actually huh that was probably not good
okay but he's getting very low on time
note that this is 4 plus two yeah he's
not going to lose on time just like that
because we have
increment this is mostly because we
don't
want want someone uh one of us playing
on time and in a stupid position just
want to have as much chess content as
possible so I'm taking here this was the
idea all along and now H this queen D5
possible or B4 maybe just push this
stuff the Knight on D6 is not uh not
badly
placed yeah I thought B3 yeah isn't this
dangerous let's do
this yeah that's a
piece that's a piece
Queen F5 yeah
to try to clarify matters maybe Queen F6
coming yeah I somehow survived this this
this little this attack that was coming
so it it probably wasn't that dangerous
to begin with but I'm not I'm not
totally sure I tend to as mentioned
underestimate those
things okay it's not uh not a win yet he
still has the pawn
let uh let me think about
it can I start a counter attack here G6
H5 H4
maybe Queen H4 is
uh is coming
possibly ah okay now he's uh he's really
trying to promote the pawn if I go to
A6 he cannot
promote I can take on F5
but um can I just Retreat the
Knight or is there something else Knight
D4 simply taking this
thing should work I don't see why not
I'm making life difficult for myself I
have this this clear impression that
this wasn't wasn't allog together
necessary a he lost some
time that's good I wasn't really sure
what uh what uh what happened there okay
so a win here this game that's good so
this little mini match at least will be
tied I can try with with white yeah I
think I got um if we do a very quick uh
recap I think this is a fair Fairly
normal standard position for this for
this opening and uh I felt that after I
I got um his his Bishop pair that I
should be okay it's it's solid I don't
have any huge weakness um it's two
Bishops but he got this this this Pawn
do going with F4 which felt dangerous
but somehow it didn't materialize I
wasn't totally sure I mean it felt like
white should have counterplay but um in
the game it wasn't it wasn't that
dangerous if we we look at it I mean I'm
not sure about about this move that I
played with this idea to put the bishop
on C5 I'm not sure if I can draw no draw
arrows here I definitely can but I don't
know how
um yeah putting the bishop on C5 this
was long this was taking time but it's
not he does not have a very um direct
attack coming
so maybe black is is okay I had some I
was a bit uh when when I was here when
it was here I was having some um yeah I
wasn't sure how good how good this this
really is but okay we'll see um what
happens in the in the second game we uh
um um I'm not sure how to do this here
actually is there some rematch button or
something or will you challenge me
again uh got messages messages here okay
I got a batch for beating a grandmas
that's
nice um but how do I actually rematch
him or does does he need to rematch me
or should I click not too not sure oh no
no I get this I can challenge
him
let's
see maybe uh I can do it like that and
then we see we see what happens yeah
this is a bit um experimental the the
whole thing because I don't really um I
don't really know this this platform so
well it's very much possible that I had
screwed it up at the end and it felt
like I'm I made uh I made some
inaccurate moves
definitely yeah if we go back to the to
the game can we do that no this is the
small board yeah not very familiar with
the
whole the whole
thing ah okay I challenged with um I
challenged with
um random
color yeah okay let's let's see what
happens um probably it's better if he
challenges me because he just knows the
ins and out of the of the platform uh
much better yeah this is on chess 24
because um Nicholas is um associated
with this company he is producing video
series for them they're very much uh
worth watching by the way it's um it's
um lots of opening related um content
also on the nimzo and boo Indian by the
way he's covering some um he's covering
some lines that uh I also have in my
book okay this is the rematch and I'm
going to start with uh Knight F3 my play
it play it safe move let's see what he's
doing he's a very good theoretician so I
expect some some serious challenge here
yeah probably E5 now or G6 these are
the moves that um are currently in
fashion of course Knight F6 is also okay
even the somewhat wacky move Knight D4
is possible yeah here I do play G3
because I don't like D4 that much D4
takes takes E6 is very much okay for
black and let's see here he can go G6
mostly G6 or
D5 I'm not sure what he's playing oh
that's interesting um maybe going for
the tarash defense I think this is
something that he at least has played in
the
past okay so we have a Tage defense
Queen
gamet um I'm trying to to remember what
he is playing I think he's playing with
C4 those lines not here here C4 would be
uh very early but Bishop E7 castles
castles Bishop G5 C4 that's that's an
early capture on on
D4 okay yeah this is comparable to to
Rubenstein Sala the classic game on the
the hanging pawns um yeah usually white
is is just grabbing this thing and then
plays
um yeah with the hanging Pawns in mind
the other move that comes into consider
consideration is E4 that's a very uh
it's also a very valid Choice um yeah
I'm I'm still going to play for the the
hanging pawns so or against the hanging
pawns attacking this this bishop and
trying to play for the D4 and C5 squares
those dark squares are the soft spots in
in in Black setup so Bishop moves
somewhere like E7 guess E7 or D6 and
then white will play Bishop E3 Rook C1
okay so he um is actually allowing the
capture H interesting if I capture um
his Pawn structure will of course be um
yeah quite seriously
improved huh I wonder if this is a good
idea
even okay and at least um it's still
it's still the bishop PA so it's uh
nothing
to uh nothing
bad can also take and play B4
maybe maybe this is an interesting try H
B4 it's immediately also was interesting
okay not an interesting
position it um it definitely should be
okay for white not uh clear to me if I
can play for anything substantial here
or what uh what exactly the evaluation
is Ah that's a good move yeah he's
trying to set up this counterplay
against E3 yeah definitely a good move
okay and he can um he can put this
bishop on C4 which makes really this is
a really good good spot for this
piece
okay yeah I wonder if I should go Queen
D4 yeah trying to
activate but it uh it leaves also E2
hanging so I will do
this which makes sense anyway because
A5 is a potentially dangerous
passer yeah Queen D4 is a
possibility next just attacking B6 and
asking him how he's how he's going to
protect
it yeah
yeah
interesting I'm not sure about all that
Queen D4 is this good he might just play
Knight
D7 and then it's not clear if the queen
is that well
plays yeah but I still like to do that
to be
honest attacking this Pawn I don't
really there's sometimes also the
possibility to capture on E3 to destroy
my structure entirely not it wasn't
really threatening I believe but um this
queen D4 so make sure this is not
happening yes this is a move that I was
a bit concerned
about quite simple but could be could be
just good um how do I play that now E2
is hanging
H I wonder is B5 a move maybe
B5 B5 but the C5 yeah this this does not
really help
much if he's going to play he can play
okay let let me cover e to for the time
being and okay I'm it's even time that's
good yeah B5 he had
C5 yeah okay of course this was possible
anyway um so is there a difference if I
take or if I don't take well I probably
not
yeah D4 I can take
A8 and D5 hangs
so well this is um interesting now
Knight F6 I'm taking C5 how is he
covering
that I mean D4 really I don't
know D4 Bishop A8 takes E3
F3 difficult those pawns uh those Pawns
are weak
definitely or at least they can easily
turn out to be a weakness
um not totally
sure I don't really see how he's uh
covering
that maybe a move
like huh move like Queen A5 or
something getting the queen out of the
defile and I don't know it does not look
great
yeah or maybe he should try D4 I mean D4
takes on E8 takes on
E3 Fe maybe there is some counter play
but it's not very realistic oh he's
falling far behind yeah this is maybe
the Practical Choice trying
to trying to um get some compensation on
my my weak King somewhat weak King okay
I'm going to take it it's um not going
to waste time with my my Bishop here or
anything um I think DF e Queen A8 Queen
D7 I don't think this can be
sufficient don't really I think that um
is there some other move what about
Queen C3 by the way this's a move Queen
C3 attacking the
bishop I don't know let's take that and
try to keep the time at Advantage which
is definitely nice to have what I'm
wondering is if I take it I should of
course take it Bishop D5 is Bishop D5 ah
this is is this is this is the issue ah
okay ah I didn't see that move oh now oh
no now is Bishop D5 coming Bishop D5
coming and possibly Queen e3
coming Ah that's that's tricky okay
maybe here
maybe this one to have Rook F3 if he
goes Bishop D5 Rook
F3 Ah that's very substantial
now um
okay um yeah my Rook is hanging
yeah so I probably have to return return
stuff here now F7 hangs I have a
pawn and the a pawn so it should be okay
at least
um
yeah securing the the match Victory or
trying to trying to go for
more I have more time on the clock and I
have a pawn so I should try for more but
how exactly Queen D3 maybe and then
Queen A1 blunders stuff h not sure is
this the draw already ah okay I actually
thought I could could look again yeah
okay but okay I'm glad to have won the
match of course he's a very very strong
player so um can be satisfied with that
I don't know this was this was very
tricky the situation where he went D4
was a highly critical situation here the
problem is black really I mean I'm
threatening Bishop takes D5 just very
simple grabbing the Central Pawn and um
yeah what should black do moving the
Knight yeah some somewhere just blunders
blunders the pawn so this uh is
definitely not uh
recommended and um yeah how is he
covering this this thing Rook E5 looks
really really weird probably just Bishop
F4 and uh I don't know maybe Queen A5
but that's also a weird move yeah maybe
D4 I don't know I took took and here I
mean if we think about the game
here this is definitely
dangerous with Queen
E3 in the mix and Bishop D5 maybe um
maybe I
had this
alternative maybe could have been
interesting yeah counterattacking the
bishop
here
I don't see I don't see a huge um a huge
issue with
it yeah it's a very tricky position very
tricky
position but um I'm unsure about the
objective Merit maybe Knight E5 is also
also a
move h i mean
this
this I I don't know I mean there is
Knight G4 possibly but is this really
enough I don't believe it maybe Queen C3
was better it's U that's it's
possible the way I played uh I think
was was uh was certainly okay I
believe went here I
took and now queen4 yeah and H I'm not
sure if I really have something else or
am I seeing ghosts here in the first
place
huh but Bishop D5 is really a threat and
queen E3 as
well yeah so I think Rook F1 looks at
least for a human player it looks like
very logical if he grabs it I go
here and
um this should be okay I
believe yeah I mean I'm an exchange up
and I have the a pawn so any counterplay
um that black has must be pretty direct
he cannot do something um elaborate here
needs to do needs to really come come
out swinging and he has some liabilities
in his position as well the queen has to
protect the rook and stuff like that
yeah Bishop D5 is is probably right okay
I went here Queen E5 and now my Rook A1
is hanging and my Rook F3 is hanging so
I really don't know if I have something
else
here yeah to be honest I think I I
really believed I could I could have
continued to be
honest I didn't think it is three
threefold already um I can I can just
continue of course and try to win but
I'm not sure I mean if you if you I mean
it's a pawn but it's just double Pawn so
uh if if white is better it is because
let's say F7 is something thing and and
and the Aon runs but yeah not not clear
to me so I'm glad to have won won this
little match in those kind of two game
format I mean this is very uh very much
dependent on on um on on luck who wants
who wins this just over two games so
yeah I hope you enjoyed those uh games
out of the ordinary something U
something else yeah and also make sure
to uh watch um yeah Grand Master hin
bait's commentary on the games he um
also recorded the the games and put it
on his YouTube channel so you will be
able to enjoy both our views um on the
games and it's always interesting for me
as well to see what the other other guy
was uh was thinking about during the
game yeah I hope you enjoyed it thanks
for watching